hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my legend of korra episode 11 video
like Mike and Brian said just got
real
in case you did not know next week is
gonna be a two-part finale episode 12 in
episode 13 we'll post at the same time
episode of 12 is called the day of the
Colossus and episode 13 the finale is
called The Last Stand new round of the
giveaway starts right now I'm giving
away another copy of the book three DVD
I have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video
careful for spoilers if you haven't seen
the episode yet but starting with top
five moments number five
Julie returns to Varrick I like the
implication that now Julie is going to
be more of a partner to him probably a
bit of a sexual partner to eventually I
mean it seems like that's the direction
they're going as socially as
Varrick seems we also got an awesome
shot of that hummingbird factory even
though most of them seem like they got
destroyed I think a few of them will
survive and they'll be able to use them
in the finale I'm really hoping that
asami and varrick get to pilot one by
themselves that'd be so funny to see
them stuck in one together or at least
Varrick and Zhu Li that actually seems
more natural it'd be like the
platypus-bear all over again I wonder if
they'd fart money out of that too that
was one of my favorite very Zhu Li
moments from book 2 a lot of things
about book 2 people did not like but I
totally loved the farting platypus bear
I'm also really hoping that Julie helps
Varrick build a bigger version of EMP
weapon cuz right now that's the only way
unless they have like a bunch of metal
benders that can metalbend that giant
mech number fourth the big montage as
the United forces roll out I felt like I
heard a collective cheer from tumblr
when Prince Iroh showed up I know
everyone would ask him when he was
coming back Dante Basco hasn't been on
the series in a while but the first time
we heard him and recognized him as the
original Zuko it was just so much fun so
any time he shows up it's really cool
that should also be a cue to listen for
other original avatar voices for
characters in the finale even if the
original characters don't show up you
know like old Toph Oh Katara old Zuko
just listen for the voices from the
original actors maybe in other
characters it was an amazing visual
sequence just showing everyone vacating
the premises the fleet moving into
position
kuvira pretty much took most of them out
whenever she fired the laser the first
time I don't think she destroyed all
their forces she just destroyed a couple
of the ships in the bay and if you
wonder why general Iroh was not on one
of those ships he's the commander of the
United Republic forces so he's like the
general of the entire
me so he moved to that tent on land
because they were planning on meeting
her on the battlefield and even though
she has that giant mech she still has a
shitload of tanks and regular-sized mix
as of the end of the episode they have
surrendered but they do have some forces
left like the United Republic forces
aren't completely decimated number three
Corps takes the airbenders to capture
Betar junior airbender mission
impossible this is so much fun I love
the infiltration Corps with just those
hand movements I wish we had more of
that I wish we had more time I thought
it was so funny that Cora said meelo
couldn't go because his farts were
Liability fart bending not an asset to
cloak-and-dagger operations before this
I never thought of him as an
uncontrollable farter usually he just
farts on cue to gross people out I think
my favorite fart bending moment from the
season so far though is when they go to
the swamps to find Korra and he tries to
fart bend the spirit vine of all the new
sub styles introduced during Legend of
Korra during the series just in general
I would say fart bending probably one of
the best I just pictured me low in 40
years with another picture at that fish
vendor next to Aang making a giant fart
sound levitating off the ground
it would be perfect next to all the
avatar pictures number two the first
reveal of the Mechagodzilla kuvira so
many awesome things going on in this
scene first off I just thought Godzilla
right off the bat so nice homage took
kaiju films necks are a huge thing at
anime but they kind of already did mix
this is just super-sized mix so you can
think Neon Genesis if you want to
although kuvira's not bonded to the MEK
that is a pretty interesting idea though
there's so much good mech anime out
there it was only a matter of time
before a court did their version of it I
can just hear everyone in the back of
their mind just going let them fight and
no I don't think it'll be as simple as
cor going into giant spirit form and
smashing the mech she did go into the
Avatar state when they were
interrogating Betar junior but she
immediately went out empty threat it
makes me feel like they're saying she's
not going to go into the Avatar state to
crush that giant mech although there's
no way she's not going to go into the
Avatar state for some reason I just
don't think it's gonna be to kill kuvira
although that option is kind of on the
table now especially Betar junior now it
seems like he's realized that kuvira has
betrayed him and my number one WTF
moment of course kuvira fires the laser
on Betar Junior and Korra it was so
heartbreaking
Betar junior you could just see the Life
Drain out of his eyes it seems like
there's nothing that kuvira would not do
to
complet or gol now they really do want
to paint her as the big bad for a
certain period they wanted you to be a
little confused as to whether or not her
intentions were noble what she was
trying to do what her ultimate goal was
now we know she's just gonna step on
everyone she can until she gets what she
wants I like that quote she had earlier
this season I always get what I want
this has really been a slippery slope
for her the only thing that I really
want that we haven't got yet is an
explanation for why she's so hardcore we
got the scene where she broke from
soo-eun where she said I'm going to fix
things but why does she feel so strongly
about that
that's the question so if there was
something super tragic that we don't
know about yet it happened when she was
a very little kid it seems like they
want us to not focus on that like they
just want us to see what's going on
right here
not to overanalyze her backstory too
much maybe Mike and Brian just want us
to see her as this immovable object I
did think it was interesting that she
sighed a little bit before she fired the
laser I do think she loves Betar jr. but
she wants to accomplish her gold more so
she wasn't lying when she said she
wanted to marry him it just she feels
like this is the only way to accomplish
her goal she's supposed to be a tragic
villain so she's not outright evil like
she wasn't playing him for the fool of
the whole time let me know that what was
your favorite moment from the episode
and do you think that kuvira was lying
about Betar jr. the whole time or do you
think that she really does love him do
some really important things to think
about as we head into the two-part
finale a couple of those hummingbird
mechs probably survived if anyone's
gonna fly them I would expect it'd be
Julie and Varrick Asami might get one
too I don't know who would pilot with
her but there are two fights that are
gonna be happening there'll be the fight
on the ground and there'll be the fight
with the giant mech so team Korra is
going to split up for a little bit like
the original team Korra and the younger
members I'm just thinking of team Cora's
like all the main characters
it really is Cuvier versus everyone else
so team Korra is now like everyone who
is not with kuvira the title of the next
episode day of the Colossus implies that
the mech the giant mech is just going to
cause a lot more trouble The Last Stand
is obviously going to be team Cora's
Hail Mary pass there been a lot of
theories about Lion Turtles core
reconnecting with past avatars I've even
heard a theory that air temple island
has its own set of statues of the past
avatars and they'll come to life and
help out too
this is felt like a very personal season
so I actually think when it all goes
in the final moments it'll just be korra
and kuvira there won't be anyone else
around that's kind of the way they ended
things with the original avatar series I
don't think that and Ozai had quite the
personal relationship that korra and
kuvira have they didn't have quite the
same history but i like the idea that
the BEI Fong family drama has replaced
Zuko's family drama it's like you have a
family at war you have a nation at war
although I think that Betar jr. is going
to come back I think this big moment
with the laser that cuvee are firing on
him I think that turned the tide the
only other option is for him to die with
kuvira he might actually try to do that
and the other really big thing that we
need to consider is what's gonna happen
with the spirit vines in republic city
there were some very prominent shots of
them covering the city they haven't done
anything thus far the spirits have
remained absent I feel like the vines
are gonna be very important to this
final battle where their core uses them
or the spirits do something or the vines
animate if they're part of a lion turtle
some of those are long shots some of
them are a little more realistic I think
that Korra will Bend the vines to help
out but let me know what are all your
big predictions what would you like to
see in the finale I know everyone wants
to see the original team avatar members
come back just overall in general I gave
the episode a solid a it was a great tee
up for what's gonna be a totally crazy
finale it's gonna be like a non-stop cry
fest now remember we haven't hit the
peak yet so it's gonna continue to
crescendo like the action will continue
to get crazier to the midway point the
climax will come when Korra just has
some giant heroic act animation
definitely top notch Mike and Bryan
spent some extra time doing reshoots
with the actors I'll be interested to
see which scenes they did or if they
change scenes after the fact we might
have to wait till the DVD comes out in
March to find out on their commentary
hopefully they'll be posting on social
media they're pretty good about posting
to tumblr about little bits behind the
scenes and stuff after episodes are
released and I'm sure after next week's
episode they'll be doing a bunch of q
and a's does it talk about all the
characters right now I am actually
really happy with where everyone's at
Kai even showed up I know everyone was
asking where the hell is Kai when is he
coming back I was surprised to hear that
so many of you guys were fans of his I
know Mike and Bryan said that this isn't
going to be like a big bending contest
between Corrin kuvira
like the final battle but there will be
a battle it'll just be stop and start
Korra is just not gonna let everyone die
in this giant bloodbath quick side note
if you're wondering how she built that
mech that's what I think she did with
the domes that she
assembled at xiaofu remember the first
thing she said when she rolled in was
disassembled the domes and then we never
found out why I think this is why so
very exciting finale I don't think it's
gonna be as simple as a David and
Goliath situation with Cora and the
giant mech but whatever ends up
happening I'm sure we'll all cry a lot
and it'll be a lot of fun Q&A tomorrow
so extra links up here if you're on your
mobile phone or your tablet actually I
think it's over here now they keep
changing where the links are is the same
as the links right here so click here
for the Q&A video I'll post that
tomorrow and click here for all my other
core videos thank you so much for
watching so let's all high-five I will
see you guys tomorrow
you
[Music]